and I feel like you're just bubbling
with insight for comics that you haven't
been able to share so that's what this
is about
oh yeah and it all out I don't mind and
I don't mind because a lot of comedians
not gonna do it that's see that's what I
give people withhold information I'm
like you can give them the sauce but
they gotta cook it they gotta cook it
now I do eventually I'm gonna charge you
knows I'm like if anybody want
information you better get it out of me
now while I'm in this just free give it
out but that's why we're here I've
noticed like the information that we sat
down the target we'll talk about it
today but that information I've gave it
to at least five to ten other comedians
have they done it no yep because it
takes it takes work man to do that part
of comedy like the administration part
you know I
I'm tired of community like okay I
started doing comedy I was doing
churches nothing but churches five years
in the game in churches then some
totally started doing clubs and I
started doing clubs and I saw why the
funniest comedians aren't working you
gotta you gotta have if you don't have a
booking agent or some kind of booking
manager somebody that's going out to get
the book is for you how are you getting
booked and I guess they think just going
around town and getting on stages but
you can't get booked but how long is
that gonna work I mean so it takes its
administration part that I don't get
like specially full time comedians if
you what do you do during the day do you
just play video games and chill and lay
down and then go out on the stage at
night is that what you think this comedy
business is about and it's not so I told
comedians in our follow up
did you do it yeah one day but man you
know alright stop complaining about
getting booked then BOOM so let's get
into it let's get into the
administrative work oh yeah so I feel
like one if we can do one at a time know
so I know you got a couple different
streams oh so I feel like this when I
worked at Clayton State I had to be in
my office at 8:00 I got off at 5 o'clock
you know luckily I was a recruiter so
sometimes I didn't have to go into you
know if I went to school I'd probably go
home and something like that but usually
you work 9:00 to 5:00 job from 9:00
five is like I see so many people
entrepreneurs they give all this energy
and their life to a job for nine to five
and they give all day like give it all
to them and complain I'm doing all this
for this company man hello give me a
raise blah blah then they jump off their
job and it's like what are you doing
from 9:00 to 5:00 you sleep in two would
win so I treat my comedy like a
nine-to-five I wake up every morning I'm
at my desk well now I'm mad I'm on the
morning show so I have to be up at 3:30
every morning from show start at 5:00
look sometimes I could get up at 4:00
and still make it because I have to have
my segment I write my segment I have to
be at this station at least by 4:30
before 5:00 o'clock cuz my segment is
the first segment that they do it starts
come on at 5:10 well earlier than that
could we have to do a teaser so I have
to be up there I go home I may take a
quick look that then I wake up and I
start minding my job I get on the
computer and start looking you know I'm
saying so but before I was doing that I
will wake up at 8 o'clock get dressed
be at my desk at 9 o'clock and when I
get off at 5:00 see you don't for myself
and you treat it you may do like a lunch
break but you try doing it sometimes I
don't sometimes I you know if you have
review work home you know the kitchen
right there you just figure something
get back to work so I don't really take
lunch breaks like that but I what I'm
saying that I treated it as if I was
working at Clayton State University yeah
I'm giving myself the same amount of
energy I gave those people and I get
tired of people not putting that energy
that they gave someone else and to
themselves I don't I don't get it that's
the thing with like it's very if we're
just keeping it a comedy basis like
being a full-time comedian and you're at
home it's like you have the freedom to
do whatever you want but it's also you
have the freedom do whatever you
shouldn't write I have trouble cuz you
know I'm full-time working from home and
I have trouble staying focused or like
committing an entire daily I mean I
maybe some days you know I do other
things like an hour and then I get like
a TD or whatever like I do how do you
keep yourself within that structure of
the day I gotta pay these bills so it's
just but needs-based
I have to pay
and it's like I did it for a job right I
did it for a company I gave them I was
on time yeah me too yeah every day yeah
yeah I wasn't missing so it's like I
don't why not do it for yourself and and
sometimes you have to UM you know
sometimes I find myself if I do that
I'll I used to leave the house and maybe
go to Starbucks like get out the house
and go work in another environment if
you're getting kind of like oh okay I'm
getting lazy you know I'm saying but
most the time and if you have your setup
you have your desk don't sit on your
couch yeah don't be relaxed you know get
a desk get a workspace and get fully
dressed take a shower but like you're
going on a job and you sit at that desk
and get to work
[Music]